my name is David Robb SEC my company is
King Kong production vehicles we
specialize in transportation for the
entertainment industry we provide
fabulous motor homes and trailers some
of the top stars in the world some of
the movies said we've worked on is with
Leonardo DiCaprio with inception Brad
Pitt Moneyball we have one that just
went out with Will Smith and went to
Louisiana
welcome into the 53-foot celebrity suite
this is our larger smokes extravagant
vehicle that we have one and a half
bathrooms seven televisions two
fireplaces security system so it's
really the same types of things you're
looking at in a luxury home we've made
this kitchen and living room area
incorporate like a great room type
feelings we have the cooktop but they
don't do much cooking in here anyhow
we've got the wine bar and we've done a
built-in type look with the Sub Zero
refrigerator right here we have one of
our guest bathrooms this is where you'll
find televisions as well this is a
custom designed shower
that's recycled glass it took artisans
two weeks to put the shower in this is a
$50,000 shower here here in the bathroom
and the living room and in the kitchen
we have heated marble floors then a
flick really one of the tray looks did
it's designed to be more residential
than being in a trailer you can move the
furniture around and he's thinking when
he has to put on his huge Batman suit
he's gonna need that type of room
sometimes days on set could be 15 18
hours so it's really a home away from
home in between takes while they're
filming our clients are looking for an
experience in our trailers that will
rival a luxury mega yacht an interior of
a corporate jet or their home